hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Freddy's 2
10 20 mode otherwise known as golden
freddy mode I know it's been a while
since I had played five nights at
Freddy's 2 but I haven't had time to
dedicate a full day to getting this done
I've been practicing all morning and I'm
using oh it's fnaf strategy on YouTube
cuz he's beaten him he beat it about a
month ago so I've been practicing it and
I'm to the point where I think I can do
it not being said there's gonna be a lot
of quiet moments cuz they need to
concentrate cuz it's really really hard
so also it's gonna be weird because I
haven't been talking since I've been
doing it but the strategy all revolves
around making sure this damn music box
is Wow
and that's all there is to it so I'll
see on the other side everybody cuz it's
gonna take some concentration otherwise
I'm gonna die right away
hello chica
I'm counting a bunch of numbers in my
head I need to stay apprised of certain
situations so that I know exactly how
many counts me because it's obscenely
precise any error is too much
yeah oh god I should not talk I can't
think I can't hear I hope that was
knowing I so hard well I couldn't do it
maybe this is bad I'm already getting
behind already behind already behind
already
Bad News Bears all-around news bears
there is a tiny gap where you cannot die
from toy Bonnie in case you didn't know
what was going on there Mon Mon Bobby
Bobby boy phoebo boy was the son of a
[ __ ] this guy with the toy bond he
doesn't want to play nice boys he still
there kill me
weird
hello Freddie
piss balls was a good one too I was
doing great
seriously pieces
no house it only two I've been doing
this for like ten minutes
so obscene
I got to not do that
lucky Oh easy there buckaroo tea
I'm not okay
I am not okay I'm not okay I've made it
to 4:00 a.m. like twice twice I made it
to five life sucks getting like a like a
I'm getting a little crazy I'm screwed
I'm screwed and screwed and screwed
screwed as money
if you guys can't follow exactly what
I'm doing please check out
oh it's fnaf Svidler it'll be there that
way you can actually see what I'm trying
to do here and apparently failing at
over and over and over spectacularly
come on
i'm getting sloppy oh god I'm getting
sloppy I gotta go I gotta I gotta stop
getting sloppy
I'm gonna shut up oh shut up oh god I've
done anything but shut up
Oh God
you don't even know no it feels so good
oh please tell me everything's still
recording cupcake everything's good all
right oh wow how everything how
everything hurts except sweating I'm
crying that was awesome aw boy ate it I
never want to do it again okay so on the
rumor mill five nights at Freddy's 3 oh
I need a minute okay so the rumor is
five nights at Freddy's 3 is coming out
eventually I don't know whenever Scott
decides to make another one the devious
bastard and was again oh do it I guess
if you guys so demand it so thank you
all so much for watching check out the
five nights at Freddy's animated down in
the description below check out more fun
dads Freddy's over there more scary
games and as always I will see you in
the next
come back for another night